Player 456 don't get any absurd ideas just
get on that plane it's for your own good
Welcome back everyone this will be my full netflix
squid game video for the ending all the easter
eggs there's so many wtf moments and references
that we have to talk about it is probably one of
the best most messed up things that you will watch
all year long if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos and big
spoiler warning for everything that happened on
squid game if you have not seen the episodes yet
there's so many messed up things that we have to
talk about so many clues that foreshadowed all
the big twists they actually did a really good
job of setting up and foreshadowing everything
that was revealed in the last couple of episodes
but we'll just start with the ending so there
are two concurrent storylines during the series
the main character who's playing inside the
games themselves and then the police officer
who's infiltrated the island trying to find his
long-lost older brother the sixth and final game
that they're forced to play is the squid game
itself paying off that opening scene from the
very first episode like literally the first couple
of minutes of the series is them as children if it
wasn't clear these are the main characters playing
the squid game as little kids the opening scene
was meant to be a metaphor for the entire series
and foreshadow everything that was going to happen
and foreshadow the big twist with the old man
and the real reason why he created the games in
the first place with the other rich businessman
to give everyone a chance to feel alive to enjoy
themselves but just doing it in the most extreme
wtf way possible have a chance to feel powerful
and like they actually had a chance at winning now
of course that doesn't make the old man or any of
the businessmen good people they're all extremely
sadistic and masochistic as hell so we'll get to
that his whole deathbed confession doesn't absolve
him of all the terrible terrible things he did for
the last 30 plus years with the games but the main
character is only able to win that final squid
game because his childhood best friend sacrifices
himself trying to do something good having just
betrayed a whole bunch of people in the previous
episodes the whole idea being that only one of
them was allowed to win so one of them was going
to have to wind up killing the other or they had
to find some other way to win the game because
even though technically there was the rule that
everyone could vote to stop the games like all the
survivors could use a majority vote to cancel the
rest of the games but if they did that then they
weren't allowed to take home any of the prize
money which was considerable by that point so the
idea at this point in episode nine is they've come
so far so many contestants have died some of them
had been their friends that they were just beyond
the point of no return like we've come this far
we can't stop now once he does wind up winning
he gets his 45 billion korean wan which is about
38 million dollars so it is a giant pile of money
and just like the police officer in the other
storyline he eventually learns the real truth
of the games who was behind them why the games
existed in the first place and what it all means
the police officer had come to the island after
finding a squid game business card amongst his
brother's belongings trying to find him just
believing that he had disappeared and fallen
off the face of the earth so when he found his
brother's squid game business card he believed
that he'd somehow gotten caught up in these games
without really knowing what was going on with the
games at the time what he does wind up finding is
that his older brother was the winner of the 2015
games so he would have survived and then later we
learned that the mysterious front man who's been
administering the games this whole time whose face
we don't see until that final episode is the man's
older brother that he's been searching for this
whole time it's meant to be this huge wtf shocking
reveal that goes hand in hand with the reveal
of the old man's true identity which the main
character also learns at the end of the finale
it was the old man this whole time some of you
may have actually guessed early and been following
the clues which i will point out in a second what
he explains is that he and his friends created
the squid game corporation that funds the games
like they created the games themselves with this
umbrella corporation because they had grown bored
spending all their money their vast wealth on all
the regular vices drugs fancy cars hookers just
weren't doing it for him so they created games
based on the games that they played as children
trying to go back to basics literally but turning
them into a battle royale running man situation
game of death whereby you had the chance
of winning millions and millions of dollars
but if you lost the game or if you broke the rules
you were killed but the old man reveals that he
had entered the games himself because he was
getting ready to die which he does in the finale
but he had wanted to have one last chance at
enjoying himself one last big thrill before he
goes out which he did successfully several times
like i said there were several clues and easter
eggs that foreshadowed the big reveal of his
identity but the actual episode itself ends on
a cliffhanger despite the fact that the creator
said that he didn't initially plan for season 2
and netflix as of right now hasn't ordered it yet
even though they claim that within the first week
or so of it airing about 100 million people have
actually watched the series it's netflix's most
popular series of all time but the big cliffhanger
ends with the main character giving half of his
winnings half of the 38 million dollars to the
mother of his best friend who sacrificed himself
and it's meant to be a big call back to the scene
in episode 1 where he claimed that his friend owes
him some of the money that he was making because
he's this big successful businessman and he was
responsible for getting him through school so that
he could get his job complaining that his friend
should at least buy him a drink so because his
friend was responsible ultimately for the main
character winning the last game he felt like he
owed his friend half of the money in the small
child that he takes under his wing and then sets
up for this better future giving him to the mother
to take care of was him keeping the promise that
he made to his female main character best friend
before she died the kid was her little brother
she'd been playing the games to earn money to
bring the rest of her family across the border
from north korea there were also a couple clues
that gave that away before they reveal the true
flashbacks but the main character is getting
ready to visit his daughter who's finally moved
to america but as he heads to his plane he sees
the recruiter from episode 1 trying to convince
another poor soul to enter a new round of the
squid games and tries to stop him from entering
he takes the squid court business card from him
so that he can't enter the games and as he boards
his plane he has a change of heart and decides to
put the people behind the game's corporation on
notice claiming that he's going to take them down
that's why he says i can't forgive you for the
things that you've done and they just keep telling
him player 456 please just get on the plane it's
for your own good and then it just slams to black
boom cliffhanger so obviously the first big twist
reveal the identity of the old man there were
several easter eggs that foreshadowed his identity
along the way that some of you probably noticed
during the first episode you notice that he's
contestant number one but his name o il nam
literally translates from korean to first man as
in the original man the man who created the games
you notice starting with the first red light
green light game and then throughout the rest of
the games he's never once afraid while they're
actually playing seemingly not worried for a
second or concerned that he might die fail or be
killed it's because he knows what all the games
are because he's watched them for the last 30
plus years and he knows exactly how to win them
you also start to see that it looks like the front
man is tracking him to help keep him alive when
things get really really crazy as if the old man
is still kind of calling the shots from inside
the dormitory like during the riot when he stands
up on the bunk and starts yelling after a little
while after a bunch of people had already been
killed the front man takes that as a cue to have
the workers stop the riot finally during that
first game you also notice the giant doll that
scans everyone for movement doesn't properly scan
him the way that it scans all the other people
during the honeycomb game he also refuses to trade
for the umbrella shape knowing that it would be
way more difficult to complete the marbles game
is administered in the exact recreation of the
neighborhood that he lived in as a child into
boot when he's playing with the main character
he totally messes with him the entire time
and then bows out effectively forfeiting to
him allowing him to continue to the next game
you do hear gunshots around the corner but you
never actually see the workers killing him even
before the marbles game he had started to look
for a way out of the games because he knew that
if he paired up with someone that only one of
them would survive that's why he goes and sits
in the corner when everyone is picking partners
later when the policeman also breaks into the
front man's apartment and starts going through
all the files of the players he scans through all
the contestants but there's no file on the old man
when they're playing the tug of war game it's
the old man who tells them the exact way to win
he claims the strategy was one that he used to
play the game as a child winning against much
bigger opponents but it's implied that he actually
learned the strategy after watching hundreds of
teams play the game the past 30 years so the other
big wtf twist reveal was the identity of the front
man being the police officer's older brother that
he was searching for there were several clues and
easter eggs just like the old man reveal along
the way that revealed the front man's identity
early on when the policeman breaks into
his brother's apartment to search for clues
he binds several questionable books around his
room like theory of desire a book on surrealist
art just clues that his brother had gone super
dark something weird was going on with him then
he finds the squid game business card in a box
wrapped with a bow that looks exactly like the
coffins that the dead contestants were cremated
in in fact the gift of the main character also
gives his daughter an episode one a gun shaped
lighter which itself is kind of a wtf thing to do
was also wrapped in a similar box that looked
exactly like the coffins later after the front man
discovers the police officer's id badge that he
left behind inadvertently he stares at it for way
way too long and this is long before he's taken
his mask off obviously he recognizes his younger
brother and orders his minions then also the
other workers to capture him alive later during
the marbles game there's a huge easter egg when
the two female contestants are bonding with each
other just procrastinating so that they can enjoy
some time together before one of them has to die
knowing that one of them will inevitably have to
die she references the 2015 korean film inside men
quoting a line from the film go to mojito and have
a glass of maldives literally saying haven't you
seen that movie the one with lee bung-hung like
i said that's literally the name of the actor
playing the front man he's a pretty famous actor
so some of you might have recognized him as the
original storm shadow from gi joe the good the bad
and the weird i saw the devil he's been in a bunch
of stuff one of the other biggest easter eggs that
a lot of you have probably noticed is that all six
games the contestants were forced to play were
depicted in the tiles around the dormitory walls
meaning that they were shown everything that was
going to happen to them from the moment that they
entered the room in day one all they had to do
was just pay attention to what was going on around
them the structure of the corporation that they
used to run the games is heavily compartmentalized
so people only know what they need to know
for whatever task it is that they're hired for
and you find that many of the workers are barely
any better off than the contestants themselves
with many of them being killed for violating the
rules of the games just like the contestants you
also probably noticed the shapes on all the
workers masks the triangles circle squares
all correspond to shapes taken from the shape of
the squid game court the actual squid game logo is
also depicted as the hair clip on the giant doll
in the first game during that first recruitment
slap game that everyone plays all the contestants
always choose the blue tile even when they get to
play another round and here's another big one too
most of the characters who wind up dying big wtf
dez foreshadow their own deaths in really karmic
ways karma does play a big role in the series ali
steals from his boss even though he was owed
all that money but then later winds up being
betrayed by sang wu who steals all of his marbles
deokusu jumps off a bridge to avoid being killed
by gang members and then later himself dies after
stepping off the glass bridge early on the female
main character threatens to slash a man's throat
then later dies after sang woo slashes her throat
seng wu who had previously tried to kill
himself later saves his friend the main
character by sacrificing himself after the group
wins the tug of war game migno talks about how
powerful she felt leaning back like that then
later gets revenge on dioxu for betraying her
by leaning back and pulling him over the edge
with her the main character even swears on his
own mother's life then finds that after he's
won the game and returned to their apartment
she's died some other really cool easter eggs for
shadowing other aspects of the games during the
first episode the main character's number 456 is
foreshadowed when he wins 4.56 million won at the
racetrack also during the final episode he winds
up asking that banker to borrow 10 000 won which
is another callback to the time at the racetrack
where he tried to get his 10 000 won back from the
attendant like hey could i get that back please
there's also a really obscure language reference
that you probably wouldn't have gotten unless
you speak korean but the female main character is
from north korea like i said but when she's in the
games with the other contestants speaking to them
she uses a south korean accent when they show
the flashbacks revealing her true identity with
her younger brother when she's speaking to him
she uses her true north korean accent when the
police officer is rifling through all the files on
the squid game corporation he finds that the games
actually started in 1988 because that's when the
first winner was crowned and even though the old
man dies in the finale the other businessmen still
continue the games as if nothing has changed and
the front man is still alive doing his job in what
about squid games season 2 what would the story be
obviously there'd have to be multiple story
lines characters going through a new round of
the games like they teased they're starting
a new round of the games collecting people
while the main character comes back trying to use
his money to infiltrate and gather enough evidence
on the games to take down the organization more
successfully than the police officer was able to
do it's not really an easter egg but really wtf
moment that was also revealed by the creator he
said that making the series was so stressful that
he lost six teeth so it's almost like he himself
was playing a squid game of sorts but if you
spotted any big easter eggs or wtf moments that
i didn't talk about during the video just write
them below in the comments everyone click here
for that brand new marvel guardians of the galaxy
3 adam warlock announcement and click here for my
brand new eternals trailer video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay safe
and just be sure to not enter any mysterious game
of death if somebody gives you a business card!